dr. Dyson can you talk about the
articles you've written that have
appeared in any peer-review journals
along those lines yeah sure you have
yeah yeah I have a not as many as many
of my colleagues do that exclusively um
but I had a prediction some years ago
published in the Astrophysical Journal
Letters right which are shorter faster
communication that might have impact to
affect the work of others I made a
prediction that there might be ten times
as many galaxies out there now and what
our van catalogs would show right and at
the time some better telescopes were
brought to bear on it and they found
like three or four times as many
galaxies yes to pull up to have to pull
10 still feel good it prompted two
searches and and a way to find them
there and recent evidence actually comes
much closer to my original prediction so
I feel pretty good about that one
example of stuff that I done but if it's
not secret publications there's
something called Google Scholar okay
it's not your normal Google search
engine but just type in Google Scholar
go there and type in my name and you'll
see all mine you'll see yourself there
that's very cool there you have it I
also study the structure of the Milky
Way galaxy oh well in the core in the
center and things like that so it's in
there if you're at the core the center
of the Milky Way if I'm not black hole
lurking there yes well no I thought it
was caramel and creamy nougat okay next
okay I couldn't help it man I'm sorry
hey did you like that cool video huh
well how about a bunch of cool videos
all commercial three plus exclusive
original content that you can't find
anyplace else
all on Startalk all access com